PRADEEP SAWLANI:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Pradeep Sawlani.
I'm an Engineering
Manager focused
on simplifying authentication
for Anthos customers.
RICHARD LIU: My
name is Richard Liu,
and I'm a Product
Manager focused
on streamlining the user
experience for authentication
for Anthos customers.
Authentication is complex.
Passwords have progressed
to keys, certificates,
and multi-factor auth.
Basic authentication
has shifted to
advanced, more-secure protocols,
such as Kerberos, LDAP, SAML,
and OAuth.
Single-tenant
monolithic applications
have evolved to multi-tenant
containerized applications,
distributed across hybrid
and multi-cloud environments.
It's clear that
authentication has
become increasingly complex,
yet, more than ever critical
to get right.
Ensuring a secure and integrated
authentication experience
requires both time
and expertise.
This leads to
on-boarding friction,
as enterprises shift workloads
to containers in the cloud,
causing delays in
modernization plans.
On the other hand,
security risks
have far greater implications.
Multiple authentication
solutions,
for example,
maintaining certificates
alongside protocols
such as OIDC,
may increase the chance
of security breaches.
And improper access control
can lead to misconfigurations
and vulnerabilities.
In fact, in a recent
survey, 78% of organizations
cite security, not
cost, as top priority
when deploying
identity solutions.
What's the end result?
Administrators
spend excessive time
on deploying
authentication solutions
and preventing misconfigurations
in their environment.
The complexity is taken further
with hybrid and multi-cloud
environments.
As enterprises modernize
their applications
and adopt solutions
such Anthos, they'll
be faced with a fragmented
identity challenge
across multiple environments.
Each environment is built on
a different identity store.
For example, Active
Directory for on-prem,
Cloud Identity for Google Cloud,
and IAM for AWS and Azure.
Many of these environments may
use the same identity provider,
or maintain a bespoke
identity solution.
For example, we have some
groups in other clouds using
IAM accounts, users in on-prem
using both Okta and Active
Directory, and users in
other clouds connecting
to Active Directory.
Mergers and acquisitions
add to the complexity.
In addition to
employee identity,
customers also need to manage
partner, end user, and workload
identity.
Essentially, the identity
solution is a mess.
So how do we enable customers
to manage their clusters
across multiple environments,
each with a different identity
provider and protocol?
During this session, we'll walk
through two separate workflows.
Users authenticating to
the Anthos Control Plane,
and workloads running on Anthos
clusters, accessing, GCP APIs
and services.
Let's start with
user authentication.
Meet Charlie, who's a
Platform Administrator.
Charlie manages a
cross-functional team
of developers focused on
building and maintaining
IT platforms within
their organization.
Charlie's team maintains
two separate environments,
GKE on-prem, and GKE on AWS.
He needs to ensure his team
has proper and secure access
to the Kubernetes API
Server to perform management
and troubleshooting tasks.
Charlie is faced with
highly-complex identity
requirements.
His organization has already
started modernization efforts
by shifting on-prem workloads
to containers, which
operate around-the-clock
to support
both internal and
customer-facing applications.
Within his team,
Alex is a developer
working on their
internal HR application,
and is provisioned within
Active Directory on-premises.
Alex needs Administrative
access to GKE on-prem clusters
to perform management tasks.
With the recent
acquisition of a startup,
Charlie's company
brought in developers,
such as Blake, that are
maintaining projects on AWS,
with identities stored in Okta.
Blake needs access to
a customer-facing SaaS
application to perform
troubleshooting
on GKE on AWS clusters.
And there's other
employees maintained
in different identity
solutions that
further add to the complexity.
So how do Administrators
such as Charlie
manage such complex
identity environments?
Let's take a look
at some options.
What are some
options for identity?
Charlie can use Kubernetes
Identity, starting
with client certificates.
However, this is
insecure, due to the need
to maintain private
keys that are typically
handled on insecure media.
Anyone with access
to these repositories
may gain unwarranted
access to the cluster.
Charlie may also opt
for a basic auth,
but that's mostly limited to
test and dev environments,
since credentials never expire,
and passwords cannot change
without restarting
the API Server.
There are also service
account tokens,
which present risks
as well, with users
that access secrets and can
authenticate as a service
account.
We recommend Open
ID Connect, or OIDC
for short, given the
long-lived-- short-lived and
refreshed tokens.
But it's not available
for every environment.
Where is it currently
available for Anthos?
Let's start with on-prem.
Customers can already leverage
external OIDC Identity
providers, such as
ADFS, to authenticate
to GKE on-prem clusters.
We currently have
GA support for OIDC,
and Alpha support for
LDAP for GKE on-prem.
We've also recently launched
a beta for OIDC access
to GKE on AWS clusters, and are
looking to add support for GKE
on GCP in the future.
Traditionally, Google
Cloud has offered
a synchronization-based
identity model,
requiring you to synchronize
identities with Google Cloud.
While this may work
for certain scenarios,
there may be concerns around
consistency and latency
for a hybrid or
multiple-cloud deployment.
With Anthos, we want to
meet you where you are,
and enable you to use
third-party identity providers
and authentication protocols.
You no longer need to
synchronize identities
with Google Cloud, or
worry about consistency
across environments.
We want to save you
time and reduce friction
during the on-boarding process.
Let's take a look at
how this will work,
with a demo starting
with GKE on-prem.
This demo will walk through
three user journeys.
Charlie will configure an
OIDC identity provider Active
Directory Federation
Services, also
known as ADFS, for his
team to authenticate
to a GKE on-prem cluster.
Alex will authenticate
using the G Cloud
CLI without requiring a
Cloud Identity account,
with the G Cloud Anthos
Auth Login command.
Alex will also authenticate
from the Cloud Console.
While this demo focuses
only on GKE on-prem,
the user experience will be the
same for any Anthos cluster,
including Anthos on AWS.
Before getting
started, Charlie needs
to perform a few steps to
enable OIDC authentication.
He'll need to reach out to his
Organization Administrator, who
manages Active Directory
Domain Services, and provision
an additional server for ADFS,
which enables OIDC support.
As you can see, Alex and
Blake are provisioned
as users in the ADFS instance
in members of the same group,
Platform Developers.
The Administrator
registers an OIDC client
in ADFS with two redirect URLs.
One for Cloud Console
and one for G Cloud CLI.
The Administrator
may customize claims
to include group membership
information in tokens for use
with Kubernetes' RBAC policies.
The Administrator provides
Charlie with OIDC client
details, and Charlie proceeds
to create an Anthos cluster
and configure OIDC in the User
Cluster Configuration file
on an Admin Workstation.
Let's take a look at this file.
There are few fields that
are important for OIDC.
The issuer URL, or
the URL of ADFS,
is used by the
Kubernetes API Server
to discover public keys
for verifying tokens.
The client ID is the
client application ID
used to make authentication
requests to ADFS.
The client secret is used by the
G Cloud CLI and Cloud Console
to exchange authentication
codes for an ID token.
The username and group
specifies claims in the ID token
to use as username in groups.
There are a few other fields
such as Scopes, Extra Perams,
and CA Path, that
can be specified
based on your configuration
and identity provider.
Deploy Cloud
Console Proxy should
be set to True if your
Open ID provider is not
reachable over the
public internet.
This employs a reverse proxy
in the Kubernetes cluster.
After creating a user cluster
with this configuration,
Charlie can create
Kubernetes RBAC policies,
allowing the platform developer
group an active directory
to view pods in all name spaces.
You can create a cluster role
and cluster role binding.
Charlie needs to create
a login configuration
file containing details
about one or more clusters
and provide each
file to developers
who want to authenticate.
You can do this using
the command gkectrl
create-login-config and pass
in the kube config for the user
cluster.
Let's try it out.
By default, this creates
a config file called
kubtctrl-anthos-config.yaml.
Let's take a look at this file.
This configuration file contains
the OIDC information provided
during cluster
creation, as well as
information about the
Kubernetes API server.
The file can be
distributed to Alex
and used to login to clusters.
Alex and Blake can
access this file,
distribute it
through a secure URL,
and store in a well-known path.
Once Alex has access to a
login configuration file,
Alex can login to clusters to
perform kube control commands.
Alex can login using the
GCloud CLI or cloud console.
The CLI experience starts
with kube control anthos
config file, with several
cluster definitions containing
information about the
identity provider in OIDC
There are two clusters
available, one of which
is configured with
ADFS for GKE on-prem.
Alex can access the API
server using the GCloud CLI
with the gcloud
anthos auth command.
Google Cloud identity
credentials are not required,
and the component can
be installed simply
by running GCloud
components install
and updating to the
latest GCloud version.
The input is a
kube control anthos
config login configuration,
and the output
is a kube config, which
will be used by kube control
to send requests to the
Kubernetes API server,
containing IDN refresh tokens.
This will create a
local kube config
in the current directory.
Let's run gcloud anthos
auth login to log in.
If Alex is out-passing
the list of clusters,
the command will exit and
print the available options
and request the user to
specify the cluster they
want to login to.
Let's login to the ADFS cluster.
It's the same command
as before, except now we
pass in a cluster argument
specifying the cluster name.
We'll perform an
open ID credential
exchange, starting a
connection to the IDP,
to allow Alex to login.
The IDP will return
an authorization code,
which we will take
and send to the IDP,
and get an IDN refresh token.
These tokens are
written to a kube config
file used by kube control.
We have a user account
under Alex's name
and we've made it
part of a group that
is defined in Active Directory
under platform developer.
We've created our backs and
applied them to our API server.
You can see a kube config
file has been generated,
so let's take a quick look
at what this kube config
file contains.
As you can see, we have
a kube config with an ID
and a refresh token
generated for our user.
If we run a command
using kube control
and the kube config
to get pods, it
will return a list of the
running pods on the cluster.
So let's try that.
So let's take a look at
how Alex can authenticate
using the cloud console.
Alex can navigate to the
cluster section in cloud console
and look at a list of available
clusters who logged in.
We previously logged
into ADFS to GKE on-prem.
Now let's try Okta with AWS.
So let's click on login.
And there's three
available login options.
Token, basic auth,
and authenticate
using an external
identity provider.
So let's try the third one.
This redirects us to an Okta
login page where we can log in.
And as you can see,
Alex has successfully
logged into the
cluster running on AWS.
We currently support
OIDC authentication
with third party
identity providers
for GKE on-prem and AWS.
In the future, we
will add support
for additional environments,
such as GCP and other clouds.
PRADEEP SAWLANI: As you
just saw in the demo,
Charlie's organization
administrator uses ADFS
with Active Directory.
Provisioning ADFS acts to
the on boarding friction,
as organization
administrators may have
vessels of funding constraints.
Or maybe, because of
compliance reasons,
provisioning ADFS us may
not even be an option.
In addition, there
may be a hidden cost
associated with managing and
mandating an ADFS server.
What if Anthos
supports authentication
with Active Directory using
LDAP or Kerberos instead
of provisioning ADFS.
Let's see how that
works with the demo.
NARRATOR: In this
demo, we will walk
through how to configure
LDAP with Anthos GKE
on-prem cluster.
LDAP support was added in Anthos
1.4.1 and is in alpha state.
It is assumed Charlie has
created an admin workstation
and admin cluster,
and has reached out
to the organization
administrator for LDAP
configuration.
Charlie creates user
cluster configuration
using gkectl command-line 2.
For our demo, we have
pre-filled configurations
specific to our environment,
which we will be using.
Let's take a look at the user
cluster configuration file.
We have named our cluster
as gke-onprem-ldap.
All fields related
to authentication
are under the
authentication anchor.
Because Charlie
is not using ADFS,
the OIDC section
is kept disabled.
If needed, OIDC and LDAP can
be enabled simultaneously.
The LDAP section is enabled
under the LDAP anchor.
The name represents the
human relabeled name
of the LDAP server.
The host field is provided by
the organization administrator
and is typically the IP address
of the host name for Active
Directory domain name services.
At alpha we only support
simple LDAP connection type.
Support for stock TLS and LDAPS
will be added in the future.
The baseDN represents
bare user entry accessed
in the Active Directory.
The user attribute is the
name of the attribute which
precedes the username in DN.
The only supported
value at alpha
is CN, which
represents common name.
Member attribute is the name
of the attribute which records
a user group membership.
For Active Directory,
this is typically
the memberOf attribute.
After filling in all
qualification fields,
Charlie creates a user
cluster, gke-onprem-ldap,
using gkectl 2.
This step will take
some time to complete.
Once a user cluster
is created, you
can check if LDAP is
configured correctly
by checking the status of
Anthos identity service.
Charlie creates our back
policy to allow users
in the Active Directory security
group platform developers view
various Kubernetes resources.
As you can see,
the group over here
represents the Active Directory
security group platform
developers.
Charlie then generates
a login configuration
for the clusters using
gkectl command-line 2.
Charlie then proceeds to
share this login configuration
with Alex.
Alex installs GCloud SDK
and uses GCloud anthos
auth login command to get a kube
config for the user cluster.
Note that the argument
to the login config
is the file which was
shared by Charlie.
Since we are logging
into an AD server,
we will select option 1.
This is the username in the LDAP
and the corresponding password.
Once successful, this
command will generate
a kube config for Alex to use.
Because Alex is a member of
the platform developers group,
he should be able to
view community resources.
Let's check that out
with the kubectl command.
This completes our
demo on how LDAP can be
used with GKE on-prem clusters.
PRADEEP SAWLANI:
Let's take a look
at how everything fits together.
On the front end,
Alex can authenticate
using CLI with GCloud
Anthos auth login,
or with cloud console by
navigating to the login button.
On the back end,
we have a service
running in the cluster called
Anthos identity service, which
is configured as a web
app token authenticator.
This service enables support
for different authentication
protocols, such
as OIDC and LDAP.
The front end works
alongside the back end
by writing tokens from
the identity provider
and generating a
kube config file
with the appropriate format
for the banket to consume.
In the future, we
will be adding support
for additional authentication
protocols in the Anthos
identity service.
We have spent some time talking
about user authentication
to Anthos GKE clusters,
but what about workloads
running on Anthos clusters?
Kubernetes workloads
aren't self-contained.
They often need to
authenticate to services
outside of a cluster.
For example, Charlie's
teams may have a workload
that beat SS to a GCS bucket.
How can you best secure
a workload accessing
a GCP API and services?
Let's take a closer look.
Today, you can use
service account keys
and store them as secrets.
Workload can use these secrets
to access the GCS booking.
But these secrets are difficult
to deploy, audit, and manage.
What if each workload could use
its built-in Kubernetes native
identity that I,
Kubernetes service account,
to authenticate to GCP?
Workload identity
for GKE enables
Kubernetes workloads, or
straight on any cluster,
to authenticate to Google
Cloud in a consistent way
without the use of
service account keys.
This currently
works for GKE on GCP
and will expand to other
environments like the AWS
or on-prem in the future.
Let's see it in action.
NARRATOR: In this
demo, we will walk
through how to enable workload
identity on an Anthos cluster
on GCP and use workload
identity to access Google Cloud
API without downloading
a service account key.
First, Charlie creates
an Anthos cluster on GCP
with workload identity enabled
with GCloud command-line 2.
Note, the argument to
workload-pool option
has to be our format
project ID followed
by the suffix svc.id.goog.
In Charlie's case, the
project ID is onprem-idp-test.
This step will take a couple
of minutes to complete.
After creating a cluster
with workload identity,
Charlie creates a
Google service account,
which will be used
to access GCS bucket.
Charlie configures iam policy
to allow service account
gsa-app1 to access the
bucket app1 artifacts using
TSU kit command-line 2.
Next, Charlie configures kubectl
to access the Anthos cluster.
Next, Charlie
creates a namespace
for the workload called app1.
Every namespace in Kubernetes
has a corresponding default
Kubernetes service account
associated with it.
Charlie creates an iam policy
binding to allow the default
service account for
the namespace app1
to use the Google
service account gsa-app1.
After this step, Charlie adds
annotation to the Kubernetes
service account.
Charlie now deploys sample
workload in the app1 namespace
to verify if the workload in
app1 one can access GCS bucket.
In this case, the sample
workload is GCloud
cloud-sdk:slim.
The bucket now should give
us an interactive shell
with cloak SDK installed.
Now Charlie will use
the gsutil command
to view to the
bucket containments.
This demonstrates port users
Google service accounts
when calling Google Cloud API.
PRADEEP SAWLANI: As you can
see, Anthos identity service,
along with workload identity,
offers a seamless solution
for managing authentication
through multiple Anthos GKE
environments, supporting
users and workloads
and providing a seamless
on boarding experience.
As a result, you can
get started quickly
with the product that has
built-in enterprise grade
security.
You can save costs and
streamline your identity
configuration by leveraging
existing identity providers.
Authentication doesn't have
to be complex or insecure.
Simplify identity with
Anthos identity today.
Thank you.